One of the joys of this week
was definitely the Bernie Sanders meme.
For sure.
It started when a photographer captured Bernie
looking very bundled at the inauguration
and then the internet fell in love
with that little Bernie nugget
and put him everywhere.
In the park with some pigeons, there you go.
There's Bernie on the subway.
Hi.
This one's my favorite,
Bernie on a
Celestial Seasonings Sleepytime tea box.
(audience laughing)
That one really, really gives me everything.
Until I saw this, it rivals
Bernie joining the cast of "Sex and the City."
Yeah, we found our new Samantha.
Exactly, there you go.
And guess what?
What?
We have Bernie at the news desk with us, Ross.
Oh, hi.
He looks right at home.
And you know, those mittens
are actually from a company in Vermont.
And they're made from repurposed sweaters.
Of course.
Can somebody make mittens up for me out of this
when I like,-
Thank you.
Also, we look like we're celebrating
with that silver mylar pop.
And I love a celebration.
Of course you do.
Okay, Drew, guess what?
We have a guest here at the news desk today,
and she's got an interesting connection to you.
The internet, it's freaking out over Jo Ellen Pellman.
The star of "The Prom" on Netflix, hello?
Yas!
Okay, so basically,
Twitter thinks that you two are twins.
Look at that right there.
What do you think?
When I see this side by side, I do see it.
You do, right?
Yes, and what an honor.
Gosh, she's the most beautiful...
So I feel honored to even be in that-
Well, you're not so proud yourself, honey.
And like, she's so good in "The Prom."
So good!
Right?
Take a look at beautiful Joe Ellen in "The Prom."
Check this out.
That was insane.
I know.
I'm really freaking out.
Don't freak out.
We have a plan, remember?
We're gonna get dressed up
and go to prom and be together, in public.
Not hide anymore.
Are you sure about this?
There's only one thing I'm sure about.
Well, there she is.
That's the beautiful Jo Ellen Pellman.
Are you there?
Yes, I'm there.
Hi, Drew.
(all cheering)
(audience applauding)
Hi, you guys.
It's so nice to meet you.
Oh my gosh,
I am like, thrilled to be here.
This is a dream come true.
(chuckles) You're gonna fit right in.
Oh, you fit right in on this show.
They put my name in everything, Jo Ellen.
I was watching "The Prom."
And when you're watching Meryl Streep, Nicole Kidman,
Andrew Rannells, James Corden,
and then this star
floats down from the heavens
and lands before our eyes.
My goodness, you have got to have the goods
to rise, you know, to meet,
let alone go above and beyond
those incredible superstars,
and you do.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh, thank you so much
for your kind words.
It really was,
like, every single day on set felt like a masterclass.
I was just trying to like observe and listen
you know, to these amazing co-stars
and just like, watch them do their thing
and like, watch what makes Meryl, Meryl,
and like, how fearless Nicole is.
Every day on set was the best day of my life.
I heard you say that Meryl Streep
never does the same thing twice.
Will you tell us about that?
'cause I always want to know what like,
a fly on the wall gets to see with Meryl Streep.
My first day ever filming with her,
it was the scene in the hotel lobby,
where I tell them that I'm gonna speak my truth my way,
and then Meryl just like screams at me.
And it was just fantastic to watch her,
like, she did a new scream
every time she did something new.
Every single way she said the line was different
and there was like, a different inflection,
a different intention.
And like, everyone else just sorta like, played off of her.
She really like, set the tone
for how this process was gonna be
and it was just gonna be like,
we're gonna try something new on every take.
Everything's gonna be fun and different.
And then, I mean, Nicole,
she's just like, the definition of fearless.
She had this idea that she was gonna eat the ice cream
in our scenes with her hands.
And every single take,
she would like, stick her hand
in the pint of ice cream
and eat the ice cream, every single take.
I was like, wow, okay.
She is committed.
She has dropped in.
Thank you for that.
(bright upbeat music)